por favor mire el video completo antes
de Vaciar la bolsa de recolección de
orina o de limpiar su catéter
este video le enseñará Cómo vaciar la
bolsa de recolección de orina unida a su
catéter supracúbico y Cómo limpiar el
catéter un catéter supracúbico es un
tubo de caucho delgado que sale de su
vejiga a través de una pequeña incisión
en la parte inferior de su abdomen hasta
una bolsa que recoge la orina
[Música]
un globo lleno de agua mantiene al
catéter en su lugar
el cuidado de su catéter suprapúbico
incluye el vaciado de la bolsa de
recolección y la limpieza de su incisión
para vaciar su catéter supracúbico usted
necesitará un paño limpio o toallitas de
papel para limpiar de derrames guantes
desechables y un cesto de basura
[Música]
asegúrese de mantener la bolsa de
recolección por debajo del nivel de sus
caderas para permitir que la orina drene
fuera de la vejiga hacia la bolsa paso 1
lávese las manos con agua y jabón y
luego sé que las
paso 2 Póngase los guantes desechables
[Música]
paso 3 sostenga la parte inferior de la
bolsa de recolección sobre un inodoro
paso 4 abre la válvula de drenaje la
orina empezará a drenar desde la bolsa
paso 5 cierre la válvula
paso 6 Quítese sus guantes desechables y
tírelos en el cesto de basura
paso 7 lávese las manos con agua y jabón
y luego séquelas
ahora empezará a limpiar el catéter
usted necesitará una bolsa plástica un
cesto de basura un paño de limpieza
limpio toallitas de papel para limpiar y
sobos de algodón o bolitas de algodón
guantes desechables una gasa estéril
dividida de 4x4 pulgadas 10 centímetros
por 10 centímetros y vendaje
sea cuidadoso de no tirar del tubo
cuando limpia el catéter
paso 1 lávese las manos con agua y jabón
y luego sé que las
paso 2 Póngase los guantes desechables
paso 3 suavemente quite todo material de
vendaje viejo alrededor de la incisión
del catéter
coloque el vendaje viejo en una bolsa
plástica y tírala en el cesto de basura
paso 4 Quítese sus guantes desechables y
tírelos en el cesto de basura
paso 5 lávese nuevamente las manos con
agua y jabón y luego sé que las
paso 6 Póngase los guantes desechables
paso 7 lave la piel alrededor de la
incisión usando agua tibia con jabón y
un paño de limpieza sé que la piel
completamente con una toalla de papel
limpia
[Música]
paso 8 lave alrededor de 4 pulgadas 10
centímetros del tubo del catéter donde
ingresa su piel con un hisopo de algodón
o una bolita de algodón y agua tibia con
jabón comience en su incisión y enjuague
su cuerpo
no limpia hacia la incisión
paso 9 coloque una nueva gasa estéril de
4 x 4 pulgadas 10 centímetros por 10
centímetros en su incisión y alrededor
del tubo del catéter en cinta la gasa en
el lugar con vendaje
asegúrese de limpiar el catéter
suprapúbico como mínimo una vez al día
comuníquese con su cirujano sí tiene
alguna pregunta sobre su catéter
supracúbico tiene escalofríos y su
temperatura es de 101 grados Fahrenheit
38 grados Celsius o más siente la vejiga
llena pero no ve que la orina drene
hacia la bolsa su incisión sangra o está
hinchada pierde orina alrededor del
catéter su orina está turbia o tiene mal
olor de arenilla o piedras en su orina o
nota sangre roja brillante en su orina
es normal ver una pequeña cantidad de
sangre u orina con un tinte Rosa después
de alguno de estos procedimientos
[Música]